ah hey everybody happy March and if you
weren't aware this month is my birthday
I will be turning 26 and turning 38 I
have five friends who do that like as a
joke Ben and it's cute but like I'm
trying to embrace my age so I I just
kind of wanted to put this out there
this uh I had a plan for this and now it
seems super self indulgent anyways uh if
last year was anything to go by you
folks really surprised me with how much
you did for me for my birthday it was
incredibly touching and amazing and
wonderful and if if folks wanted to do
something for me again this year what
would honestly be the biggest help is to
support me on patreon manage it like
hold on don't click on way that's major
I'm like like let me just say this if
you were thinking of getting me
something like off of my Amazon wishlist
that's wonderful and I'm not gonna tell
you not to do that but I hope you'll at
least consider taking however much you
were willing to spend on me for my
birthday
divide that by 12 and do that amount as
a monthly pledge on the patreon because
as much as I I love the gifts I do love
the gifts and I am really gonna look
forward to opening them the thing I want
more than anything else is to is to get
to the point where this is how I make my
living it's getting closer it's it is
it's at a frustrating distance where
like I can't just reach out and grab it
but it's right there and if you really
want to do something for me consider
that and consider it an annual birthday
present
how again however much you are leagues
at blend if you were only gonna spend 12
bucks on me pledge Ibaka month if you
were willing to spend 25 ish 2 bucks a
month
hey plus you know there's perks and
stuff
there's the discord you get your name in
the credits I've started now getting
videos up anywhere from 12 to 24 hours
before they go live so that you get
early access to them so you know that
there are things beyond just being real
nice to me but I'd appreciate that but
look if you do just want to get me a
thing link to the Amazon wish list is in
the description will be in the
description of every video that goes up
this month
yeah mejor and I'm not even saying that
self-deprecating Lee I like out I'll
wear that label proudly cuz I bought for
myself is that empowering or just messed
up
I don't know thanks everybody hope hope
you have a good month